you know
you got you got two schools of thought
okay on one hand you got people that are
saying ai is going to
automate everything and these robots are
going to replace us and we're not going
to have jobs
and our jobs are going to be taken away
and et cetera et cetera et cetera
and then i heard you saying the talk
that you know humans have created
somewhere around 3 billion jobs in the
last 200 years right that's you said
three months have
created three you know three billion
jobs 200 years
but you know ai is going to take over
everybody's job and we're going to be
screwed so what
where are you on the pendulum i mean i
think there's a um
you know there's a lot of sort of
philosophical questions here but
but look you know what we refer to as ai
um doesn't exist right now
what we have is machine learning
and machine learning is giving us the
ability with our computers to do a bunch
of cool new
things that we didn't think computers
could do before
and the way to think about that is you
know
before computers could really only do
things that you could
describe in a logical progression you
know if you could give it clear
instructions it could go do those over
and over and that's why computers have
gotten really fast at things they do
um machine learning gives us the ability
to have our computers
take on and understand things that we
can't
like we can't understand or describe
what's going on
in all of the web pages on the internet
but with
machine learning our computers can and
so now you're getting a lot of cool
machine learning party tricks which is
things like deep fakes and
you know gpt 3 which is extraordinary
is giving us the ability to have
computers write
write stories that are that sound a lot
like stories humans would write
but it still doesn't understand you know
a lot of things so
what i think about it is look you know
we hold precious these certain things
that
humans are good at uh a hundred years
ago we would have thought
you know humans were really good at you
know telling horses
what to do right and 100 years before
that
we would have thought well humans are
really good at digging holes with
their muscles in the ground and chopping
trees with
axes but we don't do that anymore um you
know we don't even do the farming like
robots do all the farming to feed us
like you are fed by robots right now um
you're basically
a a pet being babysat by robots that do
farming which is fine you know
it's freed you up to do a lot of things
and what i think you're you're seeing is
the struggle that people have when they
realize
you know that they were taking some
some self esteem from doing things that
we don't actually need you to do
right so the goal of
you know or at least the goal of a lot
of people applying technology and making
products and businesses and things is to
give you some freedom right you don't
have to
mine coal anymore you don't have to you
know
grow all your food or hunt all your food
you have to do all those things to
survive
you actually get some free time and free
time is a totally new thing
for humans humans did not have free time
before the industrial revolution
everybody just had to work to keep us
all going
more or less i'm generalizing a bit but
you
and your kids have a [ __ ] ton of free
time
and we didn't squander it you know we
invented the entertainment industry
that's your books your music your video
games
news elections all these things that
we're doing
to try and fill our free time right
because we don't actually need you
to work now what i'm saying
now is that you know people are going to
go through this
you know sometimes difficult question of
you know well
you know i don't need to be at work
anymore because computers can do my job
the truth is it usually takes about a
generation
like that's accelerated but very few
people get put out of their career
overnight
like right now we don't need more
lawyers we made too many
lawyers you know we thought because that
was a growth thing in the 90s
now we made way too many robots
computers can do a lot of what lawyers
were doing
they can read contracts they can do a
better job of understanding them than
humans can so we're done with lawyers
right so don't don't try to make your
kid become a lawyer when i was a kid
everybody wanted their
kid to be a lawyer or doctor we don't
need lawyers and being a doctor is the
worst job you can get
so you what do you want be a computer
programmer
everybody thought that i was wasting my
time now they want their kids to be
programmers
so look here's what it means i think
there are a lot of things our computers
can't do there are a lot of things our
computers can't do well
there are a lot of things even i don't
have any idea how we would solve and you
know what a lot of that is around how
you take care of humans
so if a robot takes your job i think you
should rejoice
go watch a little more netflix if that's
what you want to do
play a little more playstation but if
you got a little extra free time at the
end of the day
go [ __ ] teach right
we complain about overcrowding in
schools
we complain that there's 30 students in
my kids class with one teacher
yeah you don't even need to be a very
good teacher just volunteer
with a little bit of your free time go
teach help us get that student-teacher
ratio down from 30
to 20 or two
right how about taking care of elderly
people we can't make enough nurses
if you think your job's going to
disappear become a nurse you know what
we can't make enough nurses because we
can't make enough nurse
instructors in colleges
right the problem is we can't make
nurses faster because there aren't
enough people to teach them
right we need nurses to take care of you
because you you don't have any kids that
care about you and you're getting old
like there are a lot of things for
humans to do and we're squandering
our attention on netflix
when we should be aiming our attention
at taking care of humans so
until that gets solved i don't want to
hear people complaining
about robots taking their jobs we often
use examples like truck drivers
in america there are currently 50
000 open truck driver positions that pay
50 000 a year or more we can't make
enough truck drivers
there are no self-driving trucks not
even a single self-driving truck has
been deployed
when it does it's going to take us a
while to make
thousands of them and deploy them and
you know what those trucks don't know
how to unload
they don't know how to there's all kinds
of things they can't do so there's a job
there
probably for at least the next decade
yeah when it does
work then we'll stop hiring more but in
the meantime
you know i think people are overreacting
about these things and the point i tried
to make in that video you're talking
about is
you know the population growth curve
for planet earth goes like a hockey
stick
you know we didn't have billions and
billions of people the way we do now
until the last couple hundred years
and most of those people found jobs so
i think that we can make a few more and
i think uh
you know we need to really look at these
things and
and make better decisions about what to
panic about because you know
because uh this there's a lot that can
be done the technologies are not evil
they're not
here to destroy your life they're here
to help you these are tools for humans
to use and they're not inherently good
or evil they're just tools
so if you don't like the way things are
going
you should be helping us take these
tools and use them to create a better
world
and fight the guys who are using these
tools to take advantage of you
that's that's the game so um
yeah that's why i work on technology
because i see it as
you know the the greatest potential that
we have to
take on these big problems to make a big
difference and
help make it better for humans
[Music]
you